all right let let's go into the next
technique in that longer video um the
cou
nogget
um and again like there's a lot of good
in what you're doing that's why I'm now
picking on the on the you know picking
on the architectural elements because
they're not a freefor all because they
are
extensions of the truth of everything
else uh that provides the overall
context for what I'm doing here okay so
um that for that reason and in that way
the architectural design that I have for
Kona can inversely be used to shed light
on what I'm doing and what I'm not doing
as long as you hold yourself to their
strict angles and timings and things
like that okay so we know for
example that didn't C you nag in most
places there acceleration throws so I'm
here and I
like and I go and you know there's
different versions of it or or what have
you it doesn't really freaking matter
but all you're really doing is using his
hand to lower his
head and inertia takes over okay that
that's how they throw
okay so it's really nothing than if I
was here and I shoved him like that
that's that's all it is okay uh and we
know from my kazushi pattern analysis
that takes a lot of force to take an
upright body and reverse it in one
vertical plane that takes a lot of
energy to turn this what we want to do
instead is multiple planes um and so
then it gets light so this is when I
show this
is this force to move this Topsy Turvy
in one plane is
extremely um
cost um it raises the C the energy
expenditure you need more of it but if
you tilt it if you if you have this
plane and you have this plane and you
combine the two it gets very light at
that point this is heavier because
that's acting as a resistance to me
pushing it down but if you take it this
way then as it feeds it around with the
centrifugal energy it's pushing this one
into that position and so that's the x
pattern uh what it
does it's what we were doing in EO
yesterday so when you're when you're
here like this this takes a lot of
energy to try to get that head down into
position but when you add not just the
vertical plane but the horizontal plane
and you have a spiraling rotating cross
it's very light it's very light to do
that because the other part of his body
is helping lowering his head all right
so same thing applies in
uh well you can stay
there the first thing I want to point
out is in none of none of my techniques
will you ever throw on the 180 you're
always going to do the 270 at a minimum
okay so I would like the camera right
behind
us so if I do that 180 I'm going to only
be in one
plane and it doesn't matter
[Music]
whether you run her after the
fact it's still through him in the one
plane he has to go to the
270 which is what you saw in the EO
yesterday so when you're doing the
EO his head remember Taylor's head comes
around he has come
around and that's using those two ples
so that's the first thing I would like
for you to add coming
[Music]
around he's going to go this way but not
by me turning and now doing a vertical
plane this way
you see I'm still entering there and in
fact there not there but he is thrown
there okay we're going to play with that
uh the next thing is to get out of your
arm your arm you you there's this is no
pattern this is not a pattern never do
that okay um
so I'm want to combine two things when
he's
driving I start the angle
cancellation it's right here that's the
Tilt that I
want and to do that you are going to
transfer control from the wrist he's
driving into the elbow the elbow's right
here and again as we talked about when
when you're doing mid-range grappling
you have to know how to go from wrist
control elbow control to spinal control
and back you climb constantly so right
from the beginning you don't want to be
out on the arm and you're out here on
the arm okay you go right to Elbow
control he he drives and you're an elbow
you're you're now in his elbow the elbow
is
controlling and so we're
here that's what it should look like it
can't look like this where it's vertical
and
unbent it's here just like you're
driving
here and then the trick is keep that so
you have to be careful that as you t
con you go back to vertical
or as you throw you move your arm and
you came back to
Vertical you keep
this his leg comes around from the
inertia and that's what
[Music]
throws and if you move your arms you're
going to lose it so here's where you had
control and that's the relationship that
we now this is the throwing architecture
the angle the direction you keep
that keep that that
lowers I'm going to leave the footwork
out to demonstrate this elbow control
starts leaves
leaves and a lot of people do that
because they want to they want to use
their arm string in here you have your
relationship and this just
lowers into the Thro that's what's
making his head go lower okay
try
now you have to remember the thing with
the uh acceleration throws that they're
working in a single plane they're too
they cost too much in terms of energy um
and then they're not real throws because
if he's athletic enough he can run out
of my out of my acceleration and re
reestablish his base of support under
his line of gravity you won't fall okay
um and then you're practicing with UK
who are used to acceleration throws um
and so it's very common that they throw
well they are throwing themselves but
they'll seek agency without even
realizing it but you need to be
cognizant of when they threw themselves
and when you through them um even if
you're not throwing them for safety
reasons you you still need to be C OPP
of that so A lot of times um UK and your
UK were doing this is they're they're
already running forward into the forward
roll see and the downside of that is he
he passed the um throwing architecture
so if you pay attention he he's passed
it already you see he passed it there's
no there's no throw here now
you just kind of throw it in past
see
um what the things that I have been
saying do are are doing is as he tries
to go past
it you
see that won't change that'll make it
worse for the 270 cuz we're going this
way right but my is going that way so as
he tries to go past
it you'll hit that leg and now that IND
will really bite it um and then we're in
that same thing it's it's you're going
to go it's how you going to land and you
don't want to pay the price of the
technique for real okay
so that's important uh in terms of
actually having a throw that functions
is that they're not doing
themselves and in this case the way yuk
were doing it themselves there was no
throw at all so now I'm deceiving myself
okay if we're doing it right though you
got to be careful because your UK aren't
going to be used to it they're going to
try to run past you like anybody would
in a in a real fight if you were
accelerating them and then they end up
biting it okay so all that said to take
care of your
UK uh I usually just tell them hey don't
throw yourself don't roll yourself and
you might have to do that uh so what I
mean by that is I'll I'll feel them
start to roll run past me with that you
see and I'll go waves stay back okay
wait for me to move
you that's probably going to be the
easiest
thing and you can see as I go
here I have stopped moving they will
take another step past me do you see and
you go no that's not K me I'll move you
and then you go to
here
and okay your UK are running past you
after a while and if they have the skill
uh it doesn't matter cuz you'll hit that
leg which is what we want so this is the
last Point okay the last point is topsy
turvy must have an energy directly
affecting the top of the body and an
energy affecting the bottom of the body
so when he's about to step into that
Circle
my glute Koshi area is going to push
this leg
[Music]
as he is being brought into Chris will
you come
here hold the wrist and elbow from
here and this is the Ten
con
back here's where my kosi
is and as he goes in this pushes
that do it one one more time the camera
can make sure they get
it okay this is what Chris is doing is
this
part and the
lowering and then this is this hand
here is this glute
here this glute
here Chris goes legs push
[Music]
this opening if you pay attention at the
end it's a blending with him it's not a
throwing of him so watch when it
opens my arm and goes into here it only
opens after this has passed the head of
the point of no
return there's no weight on the hand at
that point
it's not
going
there it's
staying in non- contestation with his
grip and it's a
disarm when he gets to the bottom part
it'll come out the opening of the thumb
and index finger it's not used to throw
him
so come
here and we'll we'll game it he's he's
falling right you're about to roll it's
not the roll cuz we can't and then I
don't want to go against his grip do you
see so he starts to roll this kind of
game it use whatever you need for
balance and I'm going
out this
way one more time
here I can't pull against the fingers I
don't want him pulling me so as he's
trying let's say he's trying to pull
me that's what you're doing
okay it's not being used to lower the
head the elbow is lowering the head
[Music]
boom out okay let's try it uh one last
pointer um Tenon in in in modern iido it
it has come to mean uh this foot
maneuver this foot maneuver but that's
not what Tenon actually means ten Tenon
means to transform or to change and in
this case the relationship of uh of
either the kosi to kosi or the foot to
foot or the relationship to Naga and UK
so um as you're doing and teaching 10
con you you what you tend to see is a
lot of people will go on this ten con
here like that and then they get a baby
em and and they keep doing that okay so
if you paid attention um the ton happens
in the sense that my right
hip does go behind my left hip but my
right foot does not go
here my right foot goes here so that I'm
very close to each other
we can
go so not
here but very Bo right here so if you
were doing Cy hole you just turn that
foot and you have your feet side by
side and shees time so I've been upon
me to do that technique
that will give you the Ed you
need and that will give you all the
rotation you need you don't you don't
need to have your legs
apart you you do these throws all the
time in uh in uh like our koset for
example I know there are Iko people that
have their feet apart but your Kos n
feet are are underneath you so that you
can keep
moving this way
okay um same thing here 10 con foot
right so you can keep this circle going
Circle